brave citizen on Staten Island thank you
for your participation in this
groundbreaking experiment you are one of
the pioneers in one week you will make
history as part of a program that could
change our nation forever you will be
among the first Americans to purge the
experiment will commence with the sound
of this alarm for the next 12 hours all
crime within the Staten Island borders
will be legal and all emergency services
will be suspended weapons of class 4 and
lower are authorized for use all other
weapons are restricted you can purge as
an individual or as a group for whatever
reason you choose you may want to settle
a personal score or simply release the
rage that is burning inside of you if
you believe in the goals of the
experiment but do not wish to
participate leave a sign of support
outside your home we suggest a bouquet
of blue baptisia flowers a symbol of
rebirth news media and government
surveillance we'll operate with a heavy
presence throughout the experiment if
you are concerned about revealing your
identity we suggest you wear a disguise
or a mask however you choose to furred
are a true patriot god bless you and all
who purge and god bless the United
States of America a nation reborn
tonight allows people a release for all
the hatred and violence that they keep
up inside them this won't bring him back
it won't make you feel any better thank
you it is a night that is defining our
country citizens this will be a
tradition we celebrate every year join
the first purge how do you think says
always see you tonight
people are now calling this
controversial experiment of legalized
crime the purge you and Isaiah just stay
with me doing approach oh we're gonna be
fine on how we are here with dr. May up
Dale she came up with this experiment is
the purge a political device it is a
psychological one if we want to save our
country we must release all our anger in
one night tonight we'll see the good and
evil in everyone this is your emergency
broadcast system announcing the
commencement of the first purge our
neighborhood is under siege from a
government who doesn't give a [ __ ] about
any of us at the siren all crime
including murder will be legal for 12
hours there's a lot of good people out
there who we gonna have to protect you
all emergency services will
we gotta be prepared for anything your
government thanks you for your
participation parties you predicted a
much higher level of participation human
nature does not obey the laws of
politics
they all ex-military some funky going
down D you're sending soldiers into the
island disguised as citizens this
country needs for the store no one's
coming to help us
after tonight nothing will ever be the
same again they forgot about one thing
they forgot about us what have I got a
[Music]
strong
just remember all the good the purge
does
[Music]